♪
>> Mike: ON THIS MEMORIAL
DAY, AN EFFORT IS UNDERWAY
TO HAVE THE NATION'S HIGHEST
MILITARY AWARD BESTOWED ON
AIR FORCE SERGEANT KILLED IN
AN CONTROVERSIAL OPERATION
IN AFGHANISTAN 16 YEARS AGO.
NATIONAL SECURITY
CORRESPONDENT JENNIFER
GRIFFIN HAS THE STORY FROM
THE PENTAGON.
>> AT A MEDAL OF HONOR
CEREMONY LAST WEEK, THE
PRESIDENT HONORED NAVY SEAL
BRIT SLOW VENTRICLE SKI FOR
HIS
SLS
SLOVENSKI FAILEDATTEMPT TO SET U
SLOVENSKI FAILEDATTEMPT TO SET P
OBSERVATION POST 11 FEET
ABOVE SEA LONE WOLF NEAR AN
AREA WHERE AL QAEDA FIGHTERS
WERE OPERATING.
AIR FORCE TECH SERGEANT JOHN
CHAPMAN WAS AMONG THE SEVEN
U.S. SERVICE MEMBERS KILLED
THAT DAY AFTER A SERIES OF
MISTAKES ON WHAT IS NOW
KNOWN AS ROBERT'S RIDGE.
CHAPMAN WAS SHOT RETURNING
TO FIND NAVY SEAL NEIL
ROBERTS WHO SLIPPED AND FELL
OUT OF THEIR HELICOPTER.
INITIALLY THOUGHT TO HAVE
BEEN FATALLY INJURED.
CHAPMAN WAS LEFT BY THE
RETREATING SEALS BUT
APPEARED TO FIGHT ON ALONE.
THE AIR FORCE, WHICH HAS NOT
RECEIVED A MEDAL OF HONOR
SINCE VIETNAM, HAS BEEN
PUSHING TO AWARD CHAPMAN THE
NATION'S HIGHEST MEDAL FOR
VALOR.
>> WE KNOW NOW FROM THOSE
PREDATOR FEEDS THAT JOHN
CHAPMAN WAS NOT DEAD.
HE GOT BACK UP.
HE KEPT FIGHTING.
HE KILLED ADDITIONAL ENEMY
FORCES.
>> FOR YEARS FORMER AIR
FORCE SECRETARY DEBRA JAMES
PUSHED FOR CHAPMAN'S AIR
FORCE CROSS TO BE UPGRADED.
>> HE PAVED THE WAY FOR A
SAFE -- THE SAFE ENTRY OF
THE REINFORCING FORCES THAT
WERE COMING IN TO
FOLLOW-ONTO THE BATTLE.
>> NEW EVIDENCE, THE RESULT
OF IMPROVED TECHNOLOGY AND
ANALYSIS OF IMAGES FED BACK
FROM A DRONE FLYING ABOVE
THE ATTACK SITE SUGGEST THAT
CHAPMAN FOUGHT ON FOR MORE
THAN AN HOUR AFTER THE SEALS
LEFT HIM.
THE AIR FORCE DOES NOT BLAME
TEAM LEADER BRIT SLOVENSKI.
>> I THINK HE DID HIS
WORST DAY OF HIS LIFE.
>> FORMER ARMY DELTA FORCE
OPERATOR JIM REESE WAS IN
THE OPERATION CENTER IN
AFGHANISTAN WATCHING THE
VIDEO LIVE.
>> BEING PRIVY TO THOSE
FEEDS THAT I WAS PRIVY TO
DURING THE OPERATION THAT
NIGHT, SEEING SOMEONE
SHOOTING WHEN THOSE RANGERS
WERE COMING, IN YES, I
BELIEVE CHAPMAN WAS ALIVE.
>> THE SEALS SAY THEY DID
NOT KNOW CHAPMAN WAS ALIVE
WHEN THEY RETREATED.
>> I DO BELIEVE CHAPPY WAS
FIGHTING UP THERE.
HIS RESILIENCY, YOU KNOW, HE
PROBABLY PASSED OUT
INITIALLY.
CAGE PACK
CAME PACK
CAME BACK UP.
WHAT CHAPMAN DID WAS ABOVE
AND BEYOND BECAUSE HE WAS
THE LAST ONE ON THE